world-premiere Washington DC the most
heavily protected city on earth within
its limits
177 foreign embassies 550 elected
officials and 23,000 military personnel
in the event of an attack critical
personnel are evacuated underground
shelters open while complex defense
systems patrol the sky but nothing
stopped the virus 27 days after patient
zero
Washington fell it began with riots on K
Street than shootings in the National
Mall troops withdrew to bunkers
civilians were left in the streets
America is on the brink of collapse but
some people have survived Gardens grow
on rooftops their fences patrolled with
rifles in communities that live under
constant siege survival has taken the
form of urban warfare centuries ago on
this very soil brother fought brother
spilling blood to forge the United
States history is threatening to repeat
itself
now in the heat of summer six months
after the outbreak began a remnant of a
corrupt state lurks in the shadows ready
to engage in a new civil war agents of
the division are the only ones standing
against it
but how do you save a nation when its
enemies come from within
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
not that crash site is just ahead
Duke KITT did you guys hear that yeah
closer this time
oh this parachute dropped right through
the ceiling let me see if I can get this
it'll come in handy see you guys are
coming or what yeah all right Merry
Christmas
here's the door
[Music]
[Music]
Karp in speech the division let me just
talk to this guy okay meet us at the
sinkhole okay sure
[Music]
Wow okay definitely from the capital you
should have a new side mission on the
map yeah we're not that far okay do it
after the crash site
sounds good they're just ahead of us
Matt
[Music]
hey I see you I'll be up in a sec can't
we gotta get you leveled up I know
please help
I've been iffy toxic chemical residue
detected a lot of blue down there hey
you guys should really check this out
almost there so that's the control point
hey wait for me think deaf by Sam don't
aggro him yet me adjust my build got my
crossbow and chem launcher
can't blot out Mac can you flank them
and get a clear shot I'll take that
sniper on top wait for it got her
ow
all right let me try to get that tank
off you guys on the other side of the
plane
grenade grenade it come on
[Music]
I need your help over here
take your mind
oh I'm stuck
a little help
thanks mom oh there's a dude brushing
through the plane
yeah
yeah I'll see what I can do
got him down I'll cover you guys come on
come on
get that weak points setting my truck
thank you for the revive Meg
I've got this guy had the tank
map of the hive tonight I just lay it on
him
you're on your own
good job level up level 30 Oh Congrats
hey flair is up control point is ours
thanks guys want to check out the plane
let's go
analyzing ballistic residue like over
rough landing let's check it out
great idea let's just die
so gameplan take the capital back I
think we're ready three two I know
[Music]
please welcome the head